we are now less than two months away
from cop 26 climate summit in glasgow
but there are still very many questions
about whether it should even be going
ahead because of the ongoing pandemic
and of course the impact that it will
have that it could have on some of the
world's developing countries that are
being uh severely impacted by climate
change and i just want to ask uh both of
you and coming to you jen first i know
that you're you're a pro of these
summits aren't you i think you've been
to nine already are we ready for glasgow
you know it's impossible to tell the uk
wants to host a business as usual huge
global event in times that are anything
but usual
uh the problem is that a lot of
countries are saying they can't come
between travel restrictions vaccine
inequities the added cost of
self-isolating for example
so the those most affected by climate
change are the least able to actively
participate in this comp so so in your
mind
is that
reason to postpone
yeah
it's this is a really high risk strategy
to hold this now
all the other major un meetings related
to the environment and even some others
they've all been postponed to 2022 at
least
so we're holding this one now and i
don't see the benefits of postponing it
or upholding it now versus postponing it
what we need is action that's already
coming through pledges we need added
finance
and we don't need people to show up in
glasgow to make those pledges or make
those announcements they can do it from
home
mohammed let's bring you in here i know
you have uh originally called for it to
be postponed it's not gonna happen is it
i mean do you think that it could do
more harm than it does good if it goes
ahead
i'm afraid if the uk government cannot
hold a safe and accessible summit then
they will have to consider postponing it
they promise to vaccinate delegates you
know by the beginning of september but
we're still waiting i'm on the list for
a uk vaccine many civil society
delegates have already canceled their
trips meaning
many important voices from the front
lines of the climate crisis won't be
present in glasgow and paso
accommodation is also hugely expensive
you know travel goods remain disrupted
and we also understand now that coveted
rates are actually higher in scotland
than in many red leased countries
so i want us to have a safe summit more
than anyone but the idea of traveling to
glasgow in november with covered rates
spiking scary
and jen
you could see a scenario where some of
the delegates from some of these
countries they could be joining
virtually if not there
in person you you don't think that
that's
going to work by the sounds of it
because what people often say about
these summits is that the real
agreements the real sort of broker deals
are made in face-to-face sort of on on
the sidelines conversations
yeah i can't count the number of times
that the last sort of piece of the
solution or of the agreed outcome
arrives in a huddle of 50 people on the
floor of plenary at three o'clock in the
morning
you can't do that virtually and as far
as i know the uk hasn't made any
provisions for virtual participation in
the actual
negotiations well that's troublesome
isn't it um one of the big pieces that
needs to be put in place and it was
pledged ages ago wasn't it i think
copenhagen was this hundred billion
dollars a year financing for developing
countries to be able to meet some of
these climate goals it hasn't
materialized and how optimistic are you
muhammad that that will get something
over the line
i think hopefully the world can learn
from the mystic that we've made with the
covet vaccine rollout
the fact that vaccines haven't been
distributed fairly around the world has
allowed you know variants like delta to
actually emerge
uh you know who knows what's going to
happen in the future the fortunate thing
with climate and another a lot of
parallels i think between climate and
covingt uh is that in the case of
climate and particularly climate uh
finance you know we've been negotiating
this for danke years you know the ritual
led by the us but also including every
other rich nation uh promised 10 years
ago to provide 100 billion to some of
the most vulnerable countries in the
developing world
that hasn't materialized and and now we
are in 2021
and so what we're looking for and
starting actually with this week un
general assembly is for the u.s
particularly given the years we've lost
under the trump administration for by
them to step up and actually deliver the
promise that obama made in 2009 towards
supporting the vulnerable countries i
think between them the rich world can
actually mobilize more than 100 billion
to support the much needed you know
mitigation actions but also adaptation
actions in the developing countries i
think we are much behind in terms of
delivering solidarity
to some of the most
vulnerable countries and these things
needs to be addressed
before glasgow so it doesn't really need
to wait for glasgow and the same goes
for adaptation support but also dealing
with some of
the losses and damages that we can no
longer be able to adapt to these are
things that have been on the agenda for
the cup and and they don't have to wait
actually for glasgow they can start
making some of those things happen even
before we get together jen is that not a
powerful argument for going ahead with
cop2626 at its intended date because
then you've got a hard stop so you've
got something that you're working
towards the eyes of the world are going
to be on that summit and you might well
get those climate pledges that climate
finance pledges over the line more
countries to commit if they know that
they have that hard date to work towards
it's this strange irony we don't need
cop for climate action we need countries
to pledge set targets and deliver on
promises like finance
but
having these types of deadlines having
media attention focused on this issue
for two weeks having civil society
pushing for action
that helps and so even though it's not
an actual function or purpose of cop
one of the things that it does do is
galvanize attention and pressure
governments it's sad that we need this
it said we need that kind of pressure
but it is one of the things that cop can
do even though it shouldn't be necessary
for countries and governments to do the
right thing